[Musik]
phoenix persönlich jan fleischhauer sagt
von sich selbst er sei einer der aus
versehen konservativ wurde
erstaunlicherweise deshalb weil er sein
ganzes leben unter linken verbracht habe
im elternhaus an der universität und
dann beim nachrichtenmagazin der spiegel
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
persönlich ich freue mich hier zu sein
wieso werden sie konservativ wenn sie
unter lauter linken sind ich denke es
ist normal dass man sich seiner umwelt
anpasst
mir liegt glaube ich ein kleiner
widerspruchs teufel und wenn es zu
gemütlich um mich rum wird und alle
zuseher einer meinung sind dann springt
er hervor
jetzt waren sie 30 jahre lang der
konservative unter lauter linken beim
spiegel damit hören sie jetzt auf und
wechseln zum bürger und focus warum 30
jahre beim spiegel
ich mache jetzt diese kolumne der
schwarze kanal seit acht jahren
und da habe ich gedacht ich das jetzt
einfach noch mal bis zum rentenalter
weiter machen oder was ganz neues
anfangen und habe mich dann für die
variante entschieden ganz was neues
anfangen
natürlich also diese reibung zum
direkten meinungsumfrage die doch im
zweifel links stehen die gibt es
natürlich beim tus nicht aber weil es
auf dauer dann zu anstrengender
einfachen nein das nicht also es gibt
sicherlich auch einige die haben sich
jetzt gefreut dass ich gehe
aber mich haben doch auch aus da aus der
redaktion ganz viele mails und
zuschriften bereich zum teil auch von
leuten wie dir ich das nie geahnt hätte
die sagt manager so wirklich schade dass
du gehst wir sind zwar fast nie da einer
meinung gewesen aber es war so gut das
ist ein gipfel dich der einfach mal die
ganz andere seite gezeigt hat das war ja
auch und ist immer noch ihr
markenzeichen der einsame konservative
unter lauter linken damit sind sie
ungeheuer erfolgreich ich habe ein paar
sachen auf 120 tausend follower bei
twitter
ich glaube wenn ich die zahl richtig
nachgeschaut habe 13 millionen klicks im
letzten jahr für den schwarzen kanal
das gefährden sie doch alles dieses
ganze markenzeichen wenn sie jetzt zum
focus gehen und dann ein konservative
unter ganz vielen konservativen sind
also wie gesagt bleibt die reibung zum
zum spiegel die fett weg klar aber ich
bin mir natürlich ein dass die reibung
zum allgemeinen medienumfeld die bleibt
ja also wenn ich sag mal die ein kiosk
mit die zeitschriften angucke
süddeutsche tatzeit spiel und so weiter
oder das öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen
anmache 80 bis 90 prozent träumen doch
vom bundeskanzler robert habeck im
augenblick oder können während der
sendung noch darüber reden ob das
wirklich so ist ich bleib noch mal bei
dieser außenseiterrolle beim beim
spiegel wie haben denn die doch eher
meist linken spiegel leser auf ihre
kolumnen reagiert also wenn sie eine
online kolumne haben gibt es die
möglichkeit direkt zu antworten
es gibt ja um das forum wo sie eben auch
nicht länglich leserbriefe schreiben
müssen sondern sofort antworten können
und da sich damit anfängt da waren die
leute zum teil entgeistert als die dänen
ist die kaffeetasse aus der hand
gefallen als sich jetzt im spiegel mich
lassen ja mit dingen die sie nun gerade
im spiegel nicht erwartet haben und das
hat sich zum bisschen nachher haben sich
auch mal leute gemeldet die mir
zustimmen aber ist klar die mehrheit das
liegt glaube ich auch in der leser
reaktion sie antworten er wenn sie sich
ärgern
auf jeden fall ist das jetzt ein verlust
an meinungsfreiheit im und
meinungspluralität im spiegel weil die
spiegel leser müssen sich jetzt nicht
mehr von konservativen ideen belästigen
lassen
ja gut dann kann ja auch nachfolger für
mich finden es ist der platz ist jetzt
sozusagen der stuhl ist frei wie geht
tut sich ja ein bisschen schwer da gab's
matussek da gab es immer bruder da gab
mal fleischhauer die sind alle weg beim
spiegel irgendwie passt das nicht mehr
ich würde fast sagen die drei nacht die
sie jetzt genannt da ist jetzt jeder auf
eigene also was uns möglicherweise
verbindet bruder matussek und mich bist
ne gewisse
angst zum exzentrischen ob ich jetzt mit
den kollegen matussek den ich ja eher
für politischen wirbel kopf sagt er
also wenn ich mich politisch man nicht
vergleichen
schönes stichwort kann man auch gleich
noch aber zunächst mal sieht sie muten
ja ihren lesern auch einiges zu zb hier
ist eine kolumne von ihnen trug die
schöne überschriften nazis rein
ich werde jedoch sofort ordentliche
reaktionen hervorgerufen
das war das war die überschrift hieße
nazis rheine war eine direkt antworten
wenn man so will auf diesen damals
freier form halten ja das so frei von
tieren sehr populär gewordenen spruch
nazis raus die ich schon dämlich fand
weil das heißt nazis raus also auf mond
oder in die psychiatrie oder wo immer er
so einfach geht s ja nicht und das war
sozusagen das die dass sie sowohl eine
persiflage die cool um dr
selber hat ja ein ernsthafter
argumentierten hat gesetzt hat versucht
den punkt zu machen das sind dass wir
damals als wir echte nazis hatten auch
in deutschland zwar eine reichliche
anzahl 845 möglicherweise ja eine der
guten wege die einzuhegen war sie eben
zusagen zu demokratisieren indem man sie
in die gesellschaft rhein geholt hat das
war der ernsten kern der ko runde klar
einige leser hat das gereicht die
überschrift und um sich aufzuregen
aber da geht es ja sehr schnell da wird
dann nur die überschrift cts und dann
geschützt sind und das in sozialen
netzen
dann machen sie so einen screenshot also
foto schicken das dann über twitter
weiter viele haben auch geschrieben er
habe die kolumne gar nicht gelesen muss
ich auch nicht weiß was da entsteht und
haben sich einfach nur über die
überschrift trägt aber und das werde ich
jetzt wirklich schön
wir haben jetzt also ich meine letzte
kolumne geschrieben habe und mich von
den lesern zu verabschieden sowohl per
mails als auch gab es dann viele
zuschriften an den spiegel ganz viele
darunter auch waren die sagten also ich
habe immer mein leben lang grün gewählt
ich werde mein leben vermutlich immer
grün wählen aber ich fand es schön dass
ist sie spiegel gab weil sie mir sagt
und mal ein mal in der woche
was anderes demonstriert
wie man die welt auch sehen kann selbst
wenn ich dem nicht zustimmen
und das war mir eigentlich die liebsten
lesen die süddeutsche hc mal als chef
provokateur des spiegels bezeichnet
werden das fand ich nicht so schlecht da
hätten wir hätten nur was schlimmeres
finden können jetzt gibt es ja viele
leute sagen dieses dieser
meinungsaustausch von rechts und links
der wird immer schwieriger in
deutschland das klima wird immer
schlechter die rechten und die linken
die konservativen und die
fortschrittlichen die reden alle
überhaupt nicht mehr miteinander rechts
und links begegnen sich nur noch mit
hass wie sehen sie das
also was ist sicherlich gibt es eine
zunehmende unduldsamkeit gegenüber
anderen meinungen also das gibt es
einmal auf der seite der rechten also in
diesem fall gerade bei der afd
die delegitimierung des politischen
gegners also wenn sie annehmen dass die
bundesregierung im ernsteren arbeitet
verräterisch am deutschen volk indem sie
heimlich ein plan verfolgt das deutsche
volk gegen irgendwelche heerscharen aus
übersee oder syrien auszutauschen
dann ist das steckt ja wort auch
hochverräter drin da ist es eigentlich
etwas was sie bekämpfen müssen wo sie in
den widerstand geben müssen so das gibt
es aber auf den linken zunehmend auch
also der die argumentation geht so wenn
sie mit rechten auf einem podium sitzen
oder zum beispiel eine buchhandlung
lesen ist ja vollkommen wo3 rechte
bücher im regal stehen zu sagen da kann
ich nicht mehr lesen weil wenn ich in
einer buchhandlung lese die immer schon
in diesem fall lösung realer fall eine
linksliberale buchhandlung ist nämlich
leben coole dann legitimiere ich oder
normalisiere ich rechtes denken und
führe es in die mitte der gesellschaft
und wenn sie das zu ende denken dann
kommen sie eben zu einer wirklichen form
der segregation wo wenn sie oder ich
jemanden kennen der der falschen
gesinnung anhängt sich dann irgendwann
dafür rechtfertigen müssen dann das wäre
ja dann also wenn sie diesen kontakt
aufrechterhalten normalisierung rechten
denkens und zurzeit um mithilfe
der faschisierung der deutschen
gesellschaft und wer wird sich dem
schuldig machen da gibt es doch ein
schönes beispiel sie haben ja vorhin
ihren etwas nach rechts abgedriftet ein
spiegel ex spiegel kollegen matussek
erwähnt da gab es ja einen ziemlichen
shitstorm de rossi getroffen hat weil
man ihnen vorgeworfen hat mangelnde
distanz nach rechts außen weil sie sind
zur geburtstagsparty 65 der geburtstag
von matussek beklagen wie gesagt
ehemalige spiegel kollege und bei dieser
geburtstagsparty
da waren auch einige erklärt der
rechtsaußen erika steinbach zum beispiel
der verleger der jungen freiheit beim
sind sie da hingegangen also den
besagten kollegen mattes kenne ich seit
ich beim spiel sind also etwas hat 30
jahren und ich habe mein herz für
exzentrische personen gehabt wir haben
es hat angefreundet so unter feiert also
jemanden den sie seit sehr sehr langem
kennt dann 65 geburtstag lädt sie ein
dass der sich politisch nach rechts
entwickelt hat ist mir nicht verborgen
geblieben
nun habe ich das persönlich auch man
diese ganze ernst genommen seine
ausführung oder vorgezogen nicht damit
eben in streit geraten und mir war auch
klar dass auf dieser geburtstagsfeier
eben leute auftauchen würden für erika
steinbach und dieter stein aber es gab
auch viele alte freunde die dort waren
und das ist auch für mich eine
persönliche entscheidung wollen sie
jetzt weil jemand sich nach rechts
entwickelt meinetwegen auch nach ganz
links gibt es ja auch dem jetzt die
freundschaft auf kündigen und dann war
ich eben auf dieser geburtstagsfeier und
matthias matussek hat diese unselige
angewohnheit alles was ihm passiert
sofort auf facebook zu stellen
also hat er auf fotos dieser party
gefeiert gepostet und das hat dann
irgendwie gleicht die antifa halle
hochgezogen und hat gesagt also kuck mal
wer da alles ist unter anderem fleisch
an dem man erkennt und dann erwarte
hashtag war glaube ich mit nazis feier
damit nazis auf gut so weit so gut und
dann hat sich irgendwann auch noch der
berühmte fernsehmoderator mal
eingeschaltet und da wurde es dann
interessant weil herr böhme man
angefangen hat dann mails zu schreiben
ist diese anschriften an die spiegel
chefredaktion ob sie bei geburtstags
besuchen ihre redakteure vor
das gesetzt wird andere vorstellung ja
soll ich also also redaktion anrufen ich
bin da übrigens eingeladen darf ich da
hingehen da sind möglicherweise
gestalten die seltsam sind und dann
solche fragen wie verhält sich das mit
den ethischen und moralischen standards
des spiegels dass einer wie fleischhauer
auf geburtstags zeigt jeder kann nur
sagen da habe ich auch geschrieben
ich war student auf geburtstagsfeiern wo
raf-terrorist umgesprungen sind bis
unsere ehemalige raf-terroristen wie
astrid proll habe ich jetzt schreien die
party verlassen weil da in der ecke
raf-terrorist saß nein im gegenteil der
journalistische beruf ist doch wesen
unseres berufs mit leuten in kontakt zu
geraten
den anderen nicht mal die hand geben
würden sie haben ja selber erwähnt dass
derjenige der das erst so richtig
publizistisch hochgezogen hat das war
der fernseh moderator jan böhmermann und
sie mir das übel genommen
ich glaube eher das war eine
retourkutsche weil ich eine weile
kolumne geschrieben hatte wo ich ihn
mich über ihn lustig gemacht hatte als
den reinhard mey das zdf
und ich dachte der wartet nur auf eine
gelegenheit dass man hat ja nicht nur
sie in die ecke gestellt da waren ja
auch eine ganze menge andere anderen das
auch getan
geburtstags ständchen gespielt aber der
hat sich am ende dann wenigstens brav
entschuldigt dass er da hingegangen ist
das ist eben nicht über die lippen
gekommen er nein im gegenteil
ich fand ich finde
das und das ist der unterschied zwischen
einem demokratischen freiheitlichen
gemeinwesens einem totalitären
gemeinwesen wenn sie sich ob sie sich
rechtfertigen müssen in der
öffentlichkeit wen sie kennen und wen
sie nicht kennen das ist wie gesagt eine
private entscheidung die sollte auch
privat bleiben und hat jedenfalls
zdf-moderatorin nichts anzugehen und ich
habe der letzte satz wenn man ja hier
nicht verteidigen muss ich mal seit das
müssen wir jetzt einfach der letzte satz
war irgend einer kolumne in der ich das
beschrieben habe diesen vorgang ist und
darauf habe ich sehr viel das war auch
ganz schön viel viel habe ich gemerkt
selbst bei leuten die im internet nicht
zustimmen zustimmung bekommen war
ich möchte nicht in einer gesellschaft
leben oder besuch einer geburtstagsfeier
zu einer mutprobe wird und selbst eben
grünen und linken lager viele gesagt da
ist hat der fleischhauer unglaublich
recht das wollen wir auch nicht gut also
er kann sie hier nicht verteidigen hat
die chance in seiner sendung vielleicht
auch zum anbraten und wirklich reden wir
über die aktuelle politische situation
sie haben schon das schöne stichwort
bundeskanzler habeck in den mund
genommen die grünen hatten lauf ja ja ja
das ist das zu sagen
letztes jahr war ja der aufstieg der afg
das große thema und wo man saß auf
welchem podium auch immer nach zehn
minuten waren sie bei dem thema und das
ist jetzt wirklich vorbei also der
aufstieg der grünen ist das ist das
große idol ist das jetzt auch ein medien
halb so wie vor zwei jahren der
schutzeffekt oder ist das nachhaltig
muss das ja also ich bin ja im
beobachtungs wenn ich eine prognose
geschäft also und wie wir das über
diesen prognosen so ist also ich
erinnere mich wie 'der spiegel' von war
das vor vier jahren die piraten zu der
neuen volkspartei deutschlands gemacht
hat ja also aus dem ist zustand in die
zukunft zu verlängern und den
ist-zustand und in keiner sozusagen nach
oben zu verlängern ist immer gefährlich
wobei ich schon glaube dass das die
grünen dass das ein bisschen
langfristige ist weil sie eben für mich
ist ja keine programm partei sondern
das gefühls partei und das lebensgefühl
was die grünen und das angebot was sie
auch der der gesellschaft machen in der
bürgerlichen gesellschaft waren so
überzeugend ist das ich glaube dass das
schon mehr substanz einfach in die zehen
frei ist für future gesagt oder scheint
zu zeigen die jugend die zukunft das
grün ja nicht jugend r vorbei also wenn
die wenn die grünen jetzt nur den ersten
fehler hätten ja den sie begeistern
dann legen die nicht nur 20 prozent weil
die für junge menschen bittere nachricht
ist dass junge menschen
ich glaube fehler unter 25 gibt es etwa
drei millionen wähler über 55 12 die
wahlen in deutschland werden entschieden
von der frau ab 60 dass die wahrheit
und dass die grünen bei der letzten
europawahl so riskiert haben ist genau
dort will grund zu finden dass sie
nämlich bei den frauen ab 60 in
besonderer weise abgeräumt haben also
ein wählersegment was er normalerweise
der zu den konservativen oder cdu weil
die grünen ein thema haben gegen dass
ich unheimlich schwer argumentieren
lässt dass der klimawandel
ich würde sagen wenn sie sagen weil sie
der deutschen gesellschaft ein angebot
machen was unwiderstehlich ist das
angebot geht so
[Musik]
du willst die grünen und kannst gründer
dann so weiterleben wie du willst das
ist ja wie rosenkranz beten am sonntag
und am montag macht sie so weiter ich
meine selbst der mafiosi der am sonntag
in die kirche gegangen ist und
gebeichtet hat setzt verbrecherisches
berghammer und ich sage mal eine liste
mit einem ziemlichen klischee also diese
die die grünen mamis dem msv in einer
kindergarten fall dass da gibt es ja
genügend untersucht und das trifft so
nicht zu und ich will jetzt einfach mal
eine lanze brechen viele von grünen
wählern ist das einfach ein reales
anlegen mit dem klima anja jetzt yahoo
jetzt ist also jetzt nicht jeder
jähriger motive mit dem suv zum biomarkt
obwohl das auch die gibt so also wir
hatten erstens halte ich eine
untersuchung im spiegel aber spiegel
online
da wurden die wähler der verschiedenen
parteien gefragt nach ihren
flugbewegungen ja welche welche
wählergruppe fliegt wohl am meisten die
grünen weder welche fliegt am
allerwenigsten anhänger der linkspartei
da hat's 4 empfänger kann es sich nicht
leisten drei mal im jahr nach mallorca
zu chatten
die zahl der woche für mich war also die
krippen der faz gelesen gehabt müssen
jetzt ganz dringend was man klimawandel
tun weil freies für future die
demonstrationen und auch die
europawahlen die umfrage gezeigt habe
dass die deutschen letztlich das wollen
dass wir radikal umsteuern und der
gleichen woche wo ich das lese aus der
distanz verlautbarung der grünen
parteizentrale stolperte ich über die
zahl des in diesem jahr wo die deutschen
ja ihr grünes herz entdeckt haben die
zahl der anmeldung von suv also diesen
ganz großen spritfresser zum aller
ersten mal in deutschland die der
normalen pkw übersteigen wird das zeigt
zumindest 1 wir sind ein volk das wenn
ich es zufrieden ist jedenfalls
komplexer ist als viele leute denkt wird
also auf jeden fall können die grünen
mit dieser stefanie der deutschen
gesellschaft im moment ganz gut leben
im unterschied zu den traditionellen
volksparteien brauchen wir die spd
überhaupt noch ich meine das gibt ja
jetzt eine linke volkspartei die die cdu
ablösen kann das sind die grünen wozu
brauche ich dann noch eine spd ich
glaube dass sie in der spd brauchen ich
glaube das auch in der deutschen
wirtschaft ein gefühl dafür herrscht das
ist die spd ist jeweils schlecht wäre
wenn die spd als volkspartei von den
grünen abgelöst wird ich habe die woche
vom podium gesessen mit thomas oppermann
einen der song big five der
sozialdemokratie lange deren
fraktionschef im deutschen bundestag der
das auch sagte aus seinen gesprächen mit
wirtschaftsführern den weil natürlich
die spd eine partei ist die wie keine
andere dann doch noch immer verankert
war auch im gewerkschaftslager
in der arbeitnehmer basis und auch
deswegen originären verständnis hat für
wirtschaft und die erfordernisse von
wirtschaft und auch was es braucht ein
industrienationen wir die deutsche am
leben zu halten
da habe ich natürlich bei den grünen mit
herrn oppermann dem ober
sozialdemokraten ganz einer meinung ich
glaube das ist die spd brauche ich finde
es sehr schade auch natürlich aus
sentimentalen gründen ich komme aus
einem uhr sozialdemokratischen haushalt
meiner mutter 53 eingetreten
63 eingetreten aus begeisterung für
willy brandt das legen sie ja nie ab
also diese herkunfts bindung zu einer
partei na ich also ich habe das für dich
führen jetzt wieder anzutreten
es gibt ja auch ein paar recht ist es
zeit vielleicht vielleicht müssen sie ja
auch in die cdu eintreten weil ja der
droht ja vielleicht das schicksal wieder
spd also auch bei der cdu sieht es im
moment nicht gut aus er kann sich ja
fragen warum also wenn ich in einer
wenig einer talkshow zusätzlich über
maischberger und da sitzt mir gegenüber
herrn brinkhaus der fraktionschef der
neuen der cdu csu fraktion im deutschen
bundestag
und neben mir sitzt katrin göring
eckardt und banken was sie sagt nicht
mehr im grunde und der einzige der das
auch noch der niedersächsische
ministerpräsident der weil und der
einzige der da sitzt dann gegen den
stachel löckt bin ich und auch der
sender kommt er zu mir her bringen sagt
ein genetischer mit allem recht was ich
gesagt habe er könne das aber machen wir
nicht sagen weil da gilt als umwelt
feind dann habe ich den eindruck leute
wenn ihr so weitermacht bei der cdu
dann wird das hier nicht denn wenn alle
so sagen ja die grünen haben ja mit
allen im grunde recht ja warum sollte
die nicht dann 30 40 prozent demnächst
holen ich versuche zu verstehen was sie
sagen da sind jede menge konservative
aber die trauen sich nicht mehr zu sagen
ich bin konservativ
nein ich glaube dass die leute nicht
also den zum teil sich nicht mehr trauen
den politischen kampf und zeit
aufzunehmen
also es geht ja ganz schnell wenn eben
frei des für futures demonstriert und
man hält dagegen dass man dann
verspottet wird man hat die neue zeit
verschlafen und das
gerade männer zwischen unseren alters
nicht so ungern wie ein 74 jahre design
irgendwie abgehängt
der einfachste weg sind zeitgeistes
sagen das deb-team der jugendlichkeit
anzunähern ist sie versuchen zu umarmen
wie er überhaupt das ist ja das
interessante für mich bei falls ihr
futter und das ist die erste
protestbewegung die ja sozusagen nicht
mit protest also mit prozess angefangen
hat gegen das establishment aber am ende
gar so vom establishment umarmt wurde
und das war ja auch geradezu gefordert
von der bundeskanzlerin leben stehen ich
muss da jetzt einmal ein haben also will
man sich das mal anschaut so grün links
das steht für solidarität und
gerechtigkeit und die rettung der welt
und rechts und konservativ das steht für
ausbeutung und für egoismus ja wer
kappel danach konservativ sagt ja dann
wobei ich das dachte ich wäre immer so
ein bisschen das der vorhalt gegen die
neoliberalen die partei die mir sehr am
herzen liegt die fdp konservativ war ja
auch immer erhalt der schöpfung
familienwerte und anderes mehr gut
konservativ heißt für mich erstmal den
gesunden menschenverstand walten zu
lassen und das finde ich ganz wichtig
nicht sofort auf stimmung und
sentimentalitäten zu reagieren und das
was wir natürlich im objekt sehr stark
erleben ist schon auch eine
stimmungsdemokratie also das heißt als
er ist zum beispiel der wolf plötzlich
das heilige tier während die arme
fledermaus von denen glaube ich 250.000
im jahr geschreddert werden durch
windanlagen weil sie dadurch fliegen und
dahinten kriegen sie dann das bohrer
trauma das heißt die kleine lunge
deshalb platzen doch wald hinter der
windanlage dem boden diese fledermäuse
aus irgendeinem grund niemals jemanden
finden der sich zum anwalt ihrer macht
daran können sie aber schon erkennen
dass wir bestimmte zielgruppen oder auch
dem emotional aufladen und das
entspricht nicht immer der wirklichkeit
und wenn sie sich eben von diesem
stimmung abhängig machen
dann kann es
diese stellen natürlich auch zustimmung
zum schwimmen können und das ist
wiederum für die politik glaube ich auch
eine relativ gefährliche sache wir
glaube ich sehr deutlich auch in der
flüchtlingskrise gesehen haben
ich möchte mal ein zitat von von ihnen
hier einbringen ich gehöre zu einer
generation die nicht die gar nichts
anderes kennt als die dominanz der
linken dass das schließt ja ein bisschen
an das was sie da gerade gesagt habe wo
gibt's denn und woher kommt diese
angebliche dominanz der linken also die
gibt es natürlich nicht club würde ich
sagen
in den vorstandsetagen der deutschen
industrie und jetzt auch nicht in
handwerksbetrieben wie er überhaupt das
land her
das zeigen ja auch wahlergebnis via
konservativ ist aber wo sie 50 von 70
jahren bundesrepublik gab es einen cdu
kam genau zum großen leidwesen der
sozialdemokraten aber in dem milieu in
dem ich mich aufhalte natürlich im
möglicherweise auch sie also das heißt
da wo darüber entschieden wird wie dinge
zu sehen und zu bewerten sind also
kultur medien hochschulen natürlich
sagen eindeutig die mehrheit tendiert
zur rot grün gibt auch um fragen die das
stützen also wenn sie mal den spiegel da
gibt es auch ein paar leute die so
denken wie ich aber wenn die mehrheit
also wenn die spinde der spiegel
redaktion entscheiden könnte über die
zusammensetzung des deutschen bundestags
dann hätten die sozialdemokraten und
auch die grünen 75 prozent und das ist
ja gilt ja bis in redaktionen wie die
welt also den konservativen oder
angeblich konservativen flaggschiff des
springer konzerns aber es ist doch
irgendwie auch leichter zu sagen ich bin
links sagen jede menge leute sagen ich
bin links es gibt ja kaum jemand der von
sich selber sagt ich bin recht obwohl
die wahlen ja immer eigentlich anders
aus
sie sagen sie sind rechts das gleich ein
todesurteil da könnte ich ja da kriegte
ich gleich einen sagen deswegen wird es
ja denn mit ihnen wie beschreiben sie
sich dann selber zensieren
ich bin ja fast versucht wieder diesen
begriff zu akzeptieren das natürlich
sagen wir spätestens oder jetzt nach dem
aufstieg der afd schwieriger geworden
weil ich finde also dass da da könnte
man auch noch mal da hab ich da habe ich
ja nur mehrfach zugeschrieben warum ich
die nur in meinem leben nicht wählen
würde schon mal auf das verändert sich
kate an dieser partei diese absolute
schrecklichen humorlosigkeit ich könnte
in der partei wählen
in der nicht gelacht wird na ja ich
würde sagen begriff mit dem ich etwas
anfangen kann ist reaktionär
ich habe martin mosebach gefragt den
deutschen schriftsteller
also ich finde ja immer so konservativ
oder bürgerlich das ist so verdruckst
ich habe martin mosebach den deutschen
schrift oder gefragt denn so als
aushängeschild gibt sozusagen literat
als bei den literaten als konstruktiv
sind die konservativen ein konzert das
klingt ihm zu sehr
da konzerne ja projektion er für das
hinter den schönen begriff ich würde
noch mal gern diese dominanz der linken
aufnehmen ich meine warum jammern die
konservativen warum sagen sie nicht
einfach lautstärke ihre meinung also gut
sie sind der falsche nämlich den vorwurf
machen sie machens ja nun teuer sagen
das was angela merkel gemacht hat mit
der cdu eine zeitung nur auch sehr
erfolgreich also wie hat sie hat
natürlich wie viele kanzler die parteien
die mitte geführt sie hat in diesem fall
die sozialdemokratie überflüssig gemacht
die total sozialdemokratisierung ihrer
eigenen partei jetzt wird sozusagen das
jetzt sein findet es klug das ist das
ist in einer erst mal eine strategie
wenn sie erfolgreich ist
zu der ich als kanzler dann schon finden
kann und das ist ja eine zeit lang auch
aufgegangen
das heißt die spd so zu marginalisieren
das ist dass die spd unfähig wird an
eigenen glaubwürdigen kanzlerkandidaten
zu stellen warum ist frau merkel nicht
gerechnet hat dass es danken bücher
weise allerdings zu einem ganz la
kandidaten robert habeck reichen könnte
weil die grünen so stark werden dass sie
sitzt sein die cdu jetzt noch noch
überholen aber für eine zeit lang immer
die freiheit aber hängt jetzt verstehen
wir im vierzehnten jahr regiert mit auch
immer noch erstaunlichen umfrage werden
so das habe ich erst mal professionellen
respekt gehabt nie zu denen diesen
merkel diesen leuten gehört da ich ja
auch kein parteimitglied in keiner
partei die dann so sitzen in kleinen
kreisen und kleinen darüber was frau
merkel mit der cdu gemacht hat ich
glaube frau mag hat das mit der cdu
gemacht dass sie das sie übt auf
umfragen will die mehrheit des deutschen
volkes sondern die mehrheit meiner
anhänger das machen wir jetzt
ich würde gerne am ende dieses gesprächs
nochmal kurzen dass sie bilanz zieht
diese rolle die sie da einnehmen der
einsame konservative unter diesen linken
ist dass ihre lebensrolle bleiben sie
dabei
oder macht das auf dauer einsam macht es
einsam auf weiß ich nicht also das fand
ich eigentlich nicht nein also es gibt
ja er ist leute die sie einem auch dann
unter der hand entweder ist für häufig
pickel zither waren das sagen gar nicht
so schlecht und das ist selbst wenn die
leute dann nicht meiner meinung sind
freuen sich ja manchmal über den ton
also ich glaube dass das was ich
schreibe immer eine gewisse heiterkeit
ausstrahlt und das glaube ich
unterscheidet auch mich von vielen
journalistischen akteuren die um seine
mission vor sich hertragen also dass das
ist wenn sie so wollen gleich auch aus
einer einer linken familie komme habe
ich ja gewissermaßen die methoden und
die mittel auch die kampfmittel der
linken ja nutzbar gemacht für die andere
seite und zu den kampf mit der link
gehört ein team der hohen dass sport die
boshaftigkeit
ich hoffe dass wir diese heiterkeit auch
in dieses gespräch bringen konnten
das war phoenix persönlich diesmal mit
jan fleischhauer als lindern
berlin
[Musik]